oh that doesn't make a difference we're
beauty lighting
it's okay it's okay it's okay all right
so
[Music]
everyone minus joe sorry joe
do you guys think you guys wear
groomzilla's
what's a groomzilla no no bridezilla oh
godzilla
no not at all that's why you were
excluded i was a bridesman
zillow i was so late groomsman bill
bridesman i didn't get strippers just so
my best man didn't have to deal with his
chick asking about strippers and [ __ ]
really you did it for him
i did it for the whole group so they
didn't have to worry about all that [ __ ]
wait what
if you don't have to worry about that
you would have gone straight hell yeah
they got stripped so he's saying he
didn't get strippers
so that hit the the the groom's bride
wouldn't give him [ __ ] yeah about the
strippers oh oh when you set up the best
man thingy
when you were the best man i got my best
man that's man no no he was the groom
no i'm confused i was not the best man
you were the guy
yeah i got strippers for my other buddy
yeah big time we got him so many lap
dancing oh so you didn't get strippers
because then all of the guys would have
got in trouble yeah yeah yeah
a couple other guys would have gotten in
trouble that's lame it's all good but
it's
your wedding i'm not a group of playing
around the wives yeah
yeah [ __ ] women it wasn't the best
man it was a
one of the couple couple of groomsmen
that sucks maybe they have a dead they
have a dangerous relationship
dangerous it's not a size i'm not so
healthy yeah there's no trust i'm
jealousy
i'm jealous or maybe the dudes can't
resist temptation you gotta blame it on
the guys too
there's no trust thank you bart hey wow
i always got both sides i love it
very woke all right well i have a mid
[ __ ]
but this is written by the groom and a
lot of people
in the comments initially they assumed
it was a bride
for this situation and then he ends up
adding at the bottom by the way i'm a
man
just so you know everyone shouting
bridezilla is being
very sexist i am the man in this
relationship and while my fiance and i
agree on this issue entirely
i'm the one who posted the submission he
just wrecked himself
how could you wreck yourself any harder
than that so the
whole am i the [ __ ] thing just to
condense it
they're pretty much just they want to
know if they are the [ __ ] for
enforcing like strictly enforcing a
dress code for their wedding
so they're saying that it's a very
strict white tie dress code
white hat been very clear from the
beginning just white tie
like you know like the like casual
business casual
formal but apparently white tie is one
of those categories
yeah well because when it's a black tie
dress code you don't necessarily have to
wear black tie but i've never heard of
white
exactly explain to me what a black tie
dress code is
like a suit it's just like it's like so
everyone has to wear a white suit then
no no it's just it's just the suit get
what a white tie is that's that was my
question is lap time
tie a tire let me see yeah it's like a
black type thing oh no no wait wait
wait okay white tie is also called full
evening dress or dress suit is the most
formal in traditional it's like the most
like
the most like the with the tail color oh
suits are not allowed must be tuxedo
yeah like that
tails okay okay that clears it up to
look like a pain in the ass oh here we
go what's the difference between
white tie and black tie oh yeah please
please what's the difference okay while
a tuxedo is ideal for both it only
requires tails for a white tie occasion
so you have to have the [ __ ] tail
[ __ ] tails yeah they're having a
penguin attire
also while waitai requires a white
waistcoat black tie needs a black
waistcoat or
cummerbund chill out bro
where was his wedding at i don't know
because am i the [ __ ] anonymous
probably the magic castle
[ __ ] them the wedding had a theme what
is it with the other magicians i like to
make fun of mattresses it's funny
cheese uh the magic castle is super fun
it's pretty fun oh it's all right it was
great i've never even been out i i got
invited
i passed why that's what you're hearing
no i didn't get involved i love it
because you have it
i like magic i want to go okay anyway
we're back to this so
they're saying that they have been very
very strict with the white tight
tire white tight attire okay fair enough
even said
uh quote the invitations we sent
explicitly told our guests
that we'd be expecting from them white
tie no unnatural dyed hair like mine
no visible tattoos or piercings are you
[ __ ] me and that they were free to
decline
the invitation if they had a problem
with this so from the
rsvps wow they have been very
clear on how insanely strict they were
going to be
with this dress code and they were
saying that it's because
of the the wedding photos that they were
very very
much it would look weird if if it's a
steampunk wedding and then like
grandma's coming in with the muumuu yeah
it just doesn't fit you know what i mean
it does not fit the steampunk thing
yeah so then they're saying like uh i
mean it is their wedding i guess yeah
no i get that i guess they have a
different definition of what a wedding
is than what most people like most
people was like i want my loved ones i
want to share this moment and be like
you know in love with everything in
my marriage and these people seem to be
more in love with the image
they want cool pictures yeah cool
pictures [ __ ] my pictures hey listen
everybody wants cool pictures i mean
that's facts give me a [ __ ] break but
then if they're gonna take the picture
why don't they just have that one person
that didn't dress the [ __ ] part to
get the hell
out of the frame too i was thinking the
same thing too but
mate because some people want like
candid photos that's actually what we
wanted from our photographer and then
somehow
on the day of the wedding we forgot that
that's what we told him
it's like we don't want to pose he
started posing us spending like two
hours i'm just posing for photos
but during like that whole like
commotion i completely forgot that i was
like
wait i don't even want this and he's
like this wasn't the plan but whatever
dude we missed out on those [ __ ]
orders he's like these people love the
post jesus i thought they said no posing
in 200 posts no honestly like i'm really
disappointed and i really wish we would
have enforced that better during the day
because
almost all the wedding photos from that
photographer i
absolutely hate isn't it so hard to be
the performer
and the producer absolutely like that's
probably why bridezillas
are are so common because they have to
run everything while they're
it's their day and it's not something
you can do over exactly
there's so much pressure on that one day
and the money
seriously like after having a wedding
then you get to learn of every like
if we would redo it there's so many
things i would have done differently
yeah yeah we would we were glad we got a
wedding planner for sure
i got one you got one two are they
supposed to run everything yeah but they
just suck
like the stage manager yeah i mean she
did she did her job and all that it was
just like i guess we didn't communicate
to her that
we wanted candid wedding photos and then
so the photographer ended up like
scheduling out a block
of like photograph time whatever anyway
back to this
yeah yeah please they're saying the
struggles like quote from the
am i the [ __ ] thing it says in our
opinion while wearing knee-length
dresses
and suits rather than tucks might be
appropriate for day-to-day life they
will
doubtlessly doubtlessly look out of
place at a wedding that is supposed to
be fully formal
we are hosting a private event where we
are able to set the rules having been to
other weddings over the years we have
fully complied with the wishes of the
marrying couple and we do not see why
we should not be given the same
treatment they even write like they wear
top hats in [ __ ] town
i do not understand he still
why is this uh unreasonable request yeah
yeah he's got the monocle yeah yeah so
at this point
it seems as though people have already
rsvp'd
they again have stressed throughout this
entire planning
portion of the time that we will enforce
this and so now that they
these people have already rsvp'd and
they're getting closer to the wedding
date
people are coming in and saying like oh
can can i like wear flats after the
ceremony like you know if my feet get
tired or like grandma's feet
are gonna get tired or whatever wow and
then so they're
like we told you glass slippers on
stripper heels and so they're asking
like are we the [ __ ]
because we were very clear
and then now that we're getting close to
the wedding date now you guys want to
come in with different attire when we
were very
yes but here's the thing you're throwing
an [ __ ] party that's what i was just
gonna say
that's it you're the [ __ ] but you
have the right to be the ass yeah yeah
every single right in the world you did
communicate you're gonna be an [ __ ]
yeah exactly it it's you're not you're
doing an [ __ ] thing to begin with
yeah
like do they not understand that it's
like having a [ __ ] everyone march yeah
and i'm like don't i have the right to
do this and it's like
and people are like yo you shouldn't do
this well
i said i said i was doing it right
and you know the thing is too like when
you haven't
been to weddings before like because
when i went to my homegirl's wedding
like the first wedding i really ever
went to as a grown person
i didn't know i was supposed to even
rsvp you know what i'm saying i thought
i could just show up
until she was like hey are you going to
rsvp because we need to get the food i
was like oh [ __ ] i didn't even know
there's a lot of stuff you don't like
people don't even look at the
reservations really or the invitation
until you
are like oh what's the address for this
[ __ ] what time do i show up yeah the
wedding etiquette
it's it's kind of all over the place
right not until you get married because
i didn't know that
the couple each person that they're
inviting
is a price tag like they're literally
paying for everything
i never knew that also if you don't put
that you have a cash bar on your [ __ ]
invitation
you're a douche bag you can go [ __ ]
yourself
cousin you know who you are what's a
cash ball oh like as opposed to an open
bar a cat
like you have to pay for your drinks at
the wedding and all i'm saying is not
warning people so that they can bring
cash because a lot of us are cards only
most of the time
true i was like are you [ __ ] kidding
me so we had to go like hike to an atm
no way they couldn't even bring a
freaking little thingy like a square no
just swipe the cards
if only how are they gonna have a
destination wedding without an atm
yep it was a destination wedding it was
not a destination it might as well ben
it was like well i was thinking it was a
destination to fresno california yeah
exactly it was in orange county
santa barbara i had to drive an hour and
a half it was [ __ ] that's true
true hey you were malibu that was that
was pretty nice actually it was a nice
drive
that was pleasant drive well in case you
guys are curious
they were labeled the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's so funny how people pull such a
strict
unreasonable event and expect that other
people
are gonna comply with it like that's
just hard
but that is their i guess event
to be strict about so i get it too i'm
like i don't know
i get it it is but it's like asking
grandma to go goth because your like
whole thing is goth right so it's like
yeah yo grandma like this is my [ __ ] and
they're like yeah i'll [ __ ] do it but
like
yo do i have to wear these platform
shoes though come on man like it's it's
hard on grandma's feet
right and the thing is too they because
they wanted like their aesthetic to be
all like the same and [ __ ] right for the
pictures but
you can pick pictures to not
be in your album you'd be like oh okay
this guy has the tattoos out this guy's
not wearing his tails like take that
picture out of the album you know like
it's not that serious there's photoshop
too
they're healthy tattoos man so to them
that what they're communicating
is my aesthetic my visuals are more
important than your
presence and my friendship yeah that's
exactly literally
what they're communicating cringe yeah
cause at least for like with our wedding
people are asking like wait so what
should we wear
because they like people were being
mindful of what we would want and i was
like well this is
the theme like i don't if you guys want
to wear this you can go ahead but yeah
it's not like someone's showing up like
me
shirtless and [ __ ] shoeless with his
own fan that he brought with a battery
i forgot about this is that in frame
apparently
i'm hot but your [ __ ] was in paris so no
one wants your wedding yeah no one went
to our wedding
40 people that's tight there's a lot of
people to get to paris though i know but
we pay for our own ticket
true i was like if you can get
yourselves there because we care come to
the wedding
but that's real friendship right there
is you pay that [ __ ] buddy to go
and you don't [ __ ] [ __ ] about it
just do it yeah so they're [ __ ] on
both sides maybe
of course yeah but then yeah i got money
so i could do it but people should maybe
just [ __ ]
like these people yeah maybe like just
if you're at home you want to were you
to wear a tux just wear a tux
yeah read the [ __ ] invitation yeah
that's true
yeah if everyone has to come in with a
curly mustache [ __ ] do it
throw that [ __ ] out you you gotta take
one do it just
one night why can't everyone just look
the same for one night
how do you think like if if your feet
are [ __ ] tired man
like [ __ ] like let your auntie wear
from
after the ceremony i know it's
ridiculous and they were like nope we
told you
dude but maybe it's some [ __ ] where like
you don't want to invite your auntie who
complains about our feed problems all
the time
so that's their way of weeding it out
you can come but uh
shoes on [ __ ] good luck deal with that
figured out like with destination
weddings when you don't want
most people do it because you don't want
anybody married
here's the names of all the people we
didn't want to go
[Music]